should a screenwriter have different
piles for completed screenplays yes
absolutely
like you should know like your stuff
that's good for the marketplace and you
should know stuff that you want if
that's the career you want right like
some writers just want to be writers
that's that's all they want to do they
just want to sell sell sell and that's
totally fine other writers have pieces
that they want to wait on because they
want bigger budgets for them so they
want to build up you know their
reputation or whatever other writers
want to direct things so that they can
you know control the vision of it and so
they should hold on to those pieces
while they're building up their
repertoire selling other things John
Sayles did that John Sayles would write
huge big-budget films for the studios
they pay him a ton of money then he'd
take some that money he make his little
movies as a director you know so why is
his name escape me Damien Chazelle same
thing like if you look through his IMDB
you'll see like all these films that he
wrote and some of them were like horror
films like the dude that Melo al and
wrote horror with us you know what I'm
saying so it's like yeah okay yeah I got
that let me do that shirt give me the
money
that's fantastic and then over here is
what you got he and what is his name I
can't believe I can't remember his name
he's such a great director what it was
he directed Black Panther oh right
no no thank you okay Ryan Coogler grew
up watching Rocky loved it had a whole
take on how to bring it into the 21st
century he had done a Fruitvale station
I think and sign with his agency I
believe it was William Mars I don't know
I'm not sure but they're like what do
you want to do and he's like I want to
do Creed they're like they're Sylvester
Stallone's done don't he's done with it
don't do it do something else so he did
something else and then that made money
and they're like this is so great
we made all his money what do you want
to do free but now he made all the money
so they put him in a friend of Sylvester
Stallone and he got to pitch it
Sylvester Stallone who was done with the
character but Brian had so much passion
for the story and the character and what
Sylvester Stallone and created he's like
all right let's do it do it your way
and that's how we get creep so yeah well
what I am Damian had done a bunch of
stuff he had gotten a lot of attention
in the industry I feel like what he want
to do la-la-land musical nobody's gonna
see a musical so he went he made a blast
yes big hit Oscar winner oh my god what
an Oscar it's great what do I want to do
love him all right all right
we'll do it now they gave him 30 million
dollars for the movie that wasn't
supposed to do anything and became
phenomenon so you know you gotta have
an idea what you want to do what you're
passionate about which willing to fight
for and stuff that you you know proud of
let them do what they're gonna do with
it but again you can't have piles
unless broken record you got more
content so keep creating content
I'd like the John Sayles reference I
really loved passion fish mm-hmm you see
that one and was that considered one of
his projects or the oneself okay I
believe so I mean he had such a long
career at that point you know what I
mean so I think at a certain point you
start to if if you do it right
I think the career start to mesh where
you know you make enough films that you
know do well on that studio level you
make enough films independently that do
well and then I think at a certain point
you start they start merging they start
coming together you know I mean and it's
like this is just what you do now you
know it's kind of uh can we have no
Woody Allen's career you know he was
doing this and then this happened and
then that happened and then after a
while he was just it was just you know
the studio would give the money do the
movie which is interesting because I
have a Woody Allen quote right here oh
my god so it says if you're not failing
every now and again it's a sign you're
not doing anything very innovative yeah
yeah I think so
I agree with that you could say someone
like M night Shyamalan great made some
excellent films and unfortunately when
people didn't like for whatever reason
his other movies how it was almost like
they forgot about the other work that he
had done
yeah it was so amazing luckily he's
coming out with more things now but
short attention span memory yeah you
know the only cure for that is material
you know I mean it's like he just Spike
Lee
you know black clansmen hits all of a
sudden boom Oscar profitable everybody's
talking about Spike Lee yeah but you
know he built that up and built up
enough of material fans within the
industry you know Jordan peels like
alright let's do this thing
which makes Studios a little more
comfortable you know I mean so you you
do have to be aware of how it works
Steven Soderbergh as well mmm kinda like
I think he's always said like one for
him and one for mm-hmm
the quote-unquote system Bruce Willis
used to have the same he's to have the
same that's how he got no it was it was
six cents tell you know he won't do six
cents and they were like we want you to
do the kid he's like all right I do the
kid you let me do the six cents Disney
like all right but you got to do the kid
so he did the kid terrible woman but you
know
you